James and Michael there was I don't know
if you know this ma'am
but James Michael for some reason they
inspire a lot of fan art I'm really
curious yeah I'm curious to see how it
evolved well it hasn't evolved a lot
we're just for the end of the year we
thought we've got to make a base of fan
art with James and Michael but just to
remind ourselves of the sort of quality
that we're aiming for here are some
examples I think we've shown these
before this is just a lovely one doesn't
it get you confused Marian that's
Michael that's James Michael looks like
he's put poison in that cherry you will
notice a theme in the pictures Marian so
there's this Jay's Bible here they are
in funny enough they're on a balcony for
the moment
[Applause]
and then the classic James and Michael
in the kitchen oh yeah
Michael we go for a brownie or a fairy
cake so we Cubans out the audience to
see what scenarios they would like to
see the two of you in so where is
Victoria Godfrey where's Victoria look
look at Victoria she's lovely she's very
good necklace she's got a nice top on
this is what she wants to see this she
shut her eyes this is what I want to see
I want to see Michael entering an
airplane toilets and turning around with
a wink and James following behind
[Applause]
Victoria Victoria and she you see this
and you've revealed your secret
Victoria's Secret
quite often guys are like oh I'd love to
watch two women go at it and all that
kind of stuff and then when I've said
two women do you like to see two guys go
in there all day
no you but the trend like it's not
actually something women ever actually
see but just won't ever tell me that
they actually want to see two guys go at
it just you two it's not generic
okay my second Frank go out and I don't
think the audience today
where's-where's it Naomi Higgs oh
there's me me annex noni makes we asked
you for an idea for some artwork she
began to type and couldn't stop this is
all from her Michael loves to exercise
we know that's true however James likes
to eat cake Michael is getting a little
tired of James being so lazy
he's even starting to get a little fat
some might decide to sign James up to a
Zumba class James rocks up in the most
ridiculous outfit Michael has ever seen
that's the last time Michael will ask
James to exercise
[Applause]
well there's Matthew now Matthew thought
so long and hard about this Matthew
would like to see the two of you like
Apes picking and eating fleas off one
another's backs of course where's Peter
in bong there's Peter in ball Peter
would like to see James and Michael on a
tandem bike together yes yes I like the
gorillas gorillas on the bike
oh yes yes you can pick fleas off each
other on the bike perfect and maybe we
were driving through frog so you can do
gorillas in the mist
[Applause]
we've got a tandem bike so if you bring
in the green screen you will put you on
the streets of Paris okay if you go over
to the bike okay two of you and I think
for once James should be at the back
there is a theme about it you're never
at the back of the fan arms okay we've
talked about this last time
hey no hang on wait this Y is my god oh
because you put the stock put the
scarves on upside you're going fast
right
you see you wanted the Stars round there
you go there you go lovely lovely
okay okay so so can we have a romantic
background now please look at this it's
mega erotic okay okay
and I'll be cycling pretend to be so you
don't actually cycle
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you